bang-bang what's up guys it's Friday
lunch money time
well while she's trying to get rich
thrust was just trying to get a lunch
money right I'm here with uh I guess
general Polina tonight today so she's
got her army outfit on I let's not even
start with that we now have a new timer
twenty minutes or less that's the shot
clock we're gonna try to get everything
in in 20 minutes or less everyday for
you guys coming to you
noon ish because we don't have our [ __ ]
together get started go you have 19
minutes 30 seconds back Nancy Pelosi was
asked about whether she was optimistic
about reopening the economy next month
instead she said we can have a
depression because so many people are
out of work and that's where you have to
get the system really energized and
working let's get out those in
employment checks let's get out those
direct payments
let's get those loans freed up so what
she's saying is that's gonna energize
the economy I mean this is socialism 101
right just so we're clear the way that
they want to solve the problem is to
give you money from the government and
to free up your loans what they don't
want to do is just put American workers
back to work and let entrepreneurship
innovation ingenuity take over I
understand that but the virus is gonna
get solved so the what ends up happening
is in times of fear everyone goes oh my
god oh my god oh my god I'm really
scared I'm really scared and when they
get really scared the government comes
and says we'll save you here's money
they're literally just bribing people
and they're gonna get people addicted to
the government but when the government
controls your source of income you're
gonna do whatever the government says
what do you think it would take for
there to be riots in the streets
I don't know riots in the streets is a
pretty extreme thing I think the first
thing that will happen is that there
will be incredible backlash
intellectually on social media etc so if
you think a lot of like in 2008-2009
Zuccotti Park right Occupy Wall Street
those weren't necessary riots but they
were a physical show of displeasure or
disapproval of Wall Street the bailout
success rate
it's been pretty peaceful since then
there haven't been mass protests in the
United States or any well I mean around
the Trump administration getting elected
there was there were some of that stuff
but right now remember this is like the
perfect example like there was a
gentleman I think in Colorado don't hold
me to that who is a former police
officer and he got put in handcuffs in
front his six-year-old daughter he was
at the park playing with her and the
cops showed up and there's a photo
there's like six cops surrounding I'm
putting him in handcuffs in front of his
daughter simply because they were
outside playing right and so what ends
up happening is like okay so let me give
you this example right men in dark
uniforms with guns and weapons show up
to arrest US citizen for being outside
like that could be the headline and so
what you end up getting is like I don't
actually think that's what happened the
police department ultimately let them go
they didn't put them in jail they
apologized et cetera but we're entering
this really weird world where the same
thing happened in Illinois where cops
went into a bar and they had to shut
down the bar they arrested the people
that were inside of the bar and it
happened to be supposedly that one of
the people in the bar at the time eating
lunch was the mayor's wife right as you
get into this weird world of just like
there's economic crisis there's a health
crisis and then there's also this like
Civil Liberties crisis that's going on
as well and all of that coming together
you just have to stay alert and once
this is all over I'm curious whether
that stuff will continue or yeah and
look your family came from a communist
country right so they saw probably a lot
of this stuff in the context of Eastern
Europe and we're just you know 50 years
behind where a lot of those countries
were okay crazy right-wing on 16 16
minutes go bang bang bang bang bang said
so right after Nancy Pelosi has talked
about a depression he said this is the
best time to start a business if you're
an entrepreneur why do you say that
because basically he thinks that right
now if you can get yourself in front of
a great idea and inspired and hopefully
you venture funded this is a great time
I think he's the greatest the greatest
time well you know why right because
you're more disciplined there's more
people afraid to start things so if you
a great idea nose you don't have as much
competition is think of kind of
structurally what ends up happening so
right now there's a ton of talent that's
available because a bunch of people's
got laid off right so you can go and
pick it's tech companies and non tech
companies or laying people off this is
much talent that's available then also
the consumer is not spending a lot of
money right so what you end up having to
do is you've got to break through the
noise I'm only gonna do things that are
an absolute necessity so in terms of
using some sort of product Russian
consumer product I'm only gonna use the
things that are really really valuable
I'm not going to use fluffy things so
you kind of if you can survive through
this then you obviously have something
that people really want and then on top
of that is the discipline right you're
you you're reminded hey money's not
forever I have to build a real business
I have to actually be sustainable and so
you line up those things and it tends to
be kind of if you can make it through
the tough times
you'll flourish something well isn't it
isn't it true the lake here maybe
uber they all started during the
recession many of them did around that
time some of them started in 2008 some
of them started UHS on 11 whatever but
around that time for sure it's funny how
you can start really disciplined and
kind of veer off are you distracted as
I'm laughing because you want to talk
about discipline but you're wearing a
like look at this see literally we seem
like a little star here alright go ahead
what else force billionaire speaking of
building a business
lots of billionaires are rich because of
building a business see that transition
see how 14 minutes let's go bang bang
can you guess who richest person the
richest person in the world Jeff Bezos
yes okay what is his net worth
Bezos pre or post divorce post post
divorce I'm betting that Bezos has
hundred twenty billion dollars thirteen
113 billion oh I was close all right
what else
the youngest billionaire Kylie Jenner oh
is she or is she not self-made uh I
think she softly in the sense of her
idea she put the work in etc but people
helped her but you could say that about
anybody right
but they got help assets why well I
think the product is good ok the lip kit
but I and the reports are that she's the
one who came up with the product she's
the one who picked it she's the one who
put it together and hired a team etc
right but if I came up with the lookit I
don't have millions of followers on
social media so I probably wouldn't get
the same traction as she did yeah but
the same thing you see you say about
Sara Blakely right like Sara Blakely
when she started Spanx
she went store to store and like would
move them and like do all this stuff
right so like I don't know the whole
self-made not self-made thing is like a
pretty stupid conversation who's the
richest woman on the list
is the woman from the daughter ok well
the show's gonna be overcome only have
12 minutes so look it up later and I'll
know the answer you guys want student
loans first of all huge problem the
United States 1.7 trillion dollars in
student loans Donald Trump big Donny
Trump showed up on the podium yesterday
you know China thing and he's doing his
whole [ __ ] spiel and all of a sudden
he dropped the bomb on everyone and said
no student loan payments for six months
okay can I just say sodium she's
interrupting me today I like this this
is good now we have like an equal
opportunity type conversation go ahead
come on let's go watch the clock
it was Carol [ __ ] Baskin so isn't it
funny how this administration it's kind
of doing all the things that the people
running against Trump said they would do
the $1,200 checks the erasing the
forgiving of student or student debt
it's just really funny that so remember
what they're doing right now is a very
watered down snapshot of what mostly
Democrats had promised so stimulus check
is only doing a one-time $1,200 up to
$1,200 yeah right so it's not true ubi
but it's definite direction
student loans they are not forgiving the
student loans they're saying six-month
deferral and maybe more a step in that
direction but not the full thing and so
what ends up happening though is I don't
think that they're going to be able to
avoid eventually getting to a ubi type
program and also I don't know if they go
full-bore forgive all the student loans
or there's some sort of you know fifty
percent or something that helps people
on the payments whatever but 1.7
trillion dollars in student debt is wild
right I know but I think once you kind
of let the genie out of the bottle it's
very hard to put it back yeah or if you
give people a taste of ubi once you give
people absolutely well that's what I'm
saying is like III think that they're
trying not to go do the full-bore thing
but once you start down that slope
you're gonna end up there but here's the
bigger problem is this is just another
bribe the $1,200 broad the student loan
bribe because what ends up happening is
the US government is going to get blamed
for this financial crisis right in
2008-2009 the banks got blamed everyone
was like you know screw the banks Occupy
Wall Street but banks were over
leveraged mortgage-backed securities is
this you know really exotic type thing
that I don't understand like it's the
bank's fault coming out of this
financial crisis they're gonna say the
US government told us all to go home but
they mandated I shut down my business
there's no one to be mad at other than
the government and so people gonna do is
they're gonna turn they're like dude you
caused this financial crisis and yes it
was in response to this virus but what
they're gonna say is you shut down my
business right and so what they're doing
right now is they're trying to do these
little things to get people to see hey
we're helping we're helping you here's
1,200 bucks we're gonna defer your
student loans we're gonna give you rent
abatement or deferrals etc and those
things do help people to some degree but
the only thing that is going to solve
the problem is get people back to work
you got to get people back to work right
and until you do that it's like what
Nancy Pelosi saying is like it's all
your source you see the notifications
all right what's next chicken wing so
what the heck is so chicken wing sales
generally peak only twice a year during
the Super Bowl and the NC double-a
tournament well you can say either one
you know why they say NC double-a got
them I got a genius on my hands
because canceled because of coronavirus
there is now a massive surplus of
chicken wings in the United States
because that they were all prepared for
the n-c-double-a tournament yeah okay
look how many well like there are nearly
1.25 million pounds of wings sold the
week of the n-c-double-a tournament and
this week only 430 that's not okay so
basically one-third of what they thought
was gonna sell is sold so there's about
800,000 pounds of chicken wings or is it
affecting prices do we know like could
we go buy chicken wings right now at a
huge discount and freeze them and then
just eat them throughout the year and
feel like geniuses we bought food cheap
like Buffalo Wild Wings hooters swing
stop all those are what are the best
wings you've ever had atomic wings
hooters Purina hooters yes with you
unfortunately my mother's favorite
restaurant is hooters no lie as Felina
[Laughter]
legitimately my mom's favorite
restaurant is Hooters and if you ask her
why she likes it she'll tell you that
they have the best smothered chicken
sandwiches in the world it's a chicken
sandwich with cheese over smoke but yes
they are now being sold for a little
over a little over than $1 per pound
roughly half of what they went for
around the Superbowl
so we should definitely go stock up on
chicken wings we actually bought chicken
with yesterday but we but we should go
buy more and freeze them and then just
eat them periodically over the over the
year that's how you save money
everyone's just trying to get a lunch
money right you see what I'm saying all
right listen guys this week's been fun
here's what we're gonna do
last Friday we gave out $100 - yeah I'm
going run whatever we got seven minutes
I feel like I got all the time in the
world
it was Gerald [ __ ] bass in by the way
Tiger King may actually be coming out
with the new episode right are they
gonna do it do you think that they're
gonna find out the Carroll Baskin got
arrested for killing her husband no I
think they're probably gonna look at
that weird nanny Jeff flow situation
that's gone on the nanny Jeff flow oh
they got like a model or whatever ask
them yeah okay whatever that's fine but
Trump made part enjoy exotic is it big
Z's funny um we are going to give out
another hundred dollars free lunch money
for watching the show you made it this
far there's six minutes left
free lunch money while Wall Street is
trying to get rich the Russell's are
just trying to get our lunch money so
we're gonna give out some lunch money
what you have to do is you have to take
the URL to this video you have to tweet
it use the hashtag lunch money and what
should they do this week last week they
told us something they learned which
they tell us this week tell us your
favorite joke from the show ok I have
all the jokes - Carol basket joke
alright that's fine in the morning
ok you can't name all the jokes ok so
here's the deal take the URL to the
video tweet it use hash tag lunch money
include your favorite joke from the show
or tell us why you love it and we will
pick one person by the end of the
weekend what calm please like I said we
will pick one person over the weekend we
will send them a hundred dollars on
dental or I will send it to you in
Bitcoin if you wanted a Bitcoin and then
on Monday we will announce who the
winner is
so URL can tweet it hashtag lunch money
no well they're giving out 1,200 us
although you know a hundred dollars
it was Carole [ __ ] mask all right
guys listen we're having a ton of fun
recording this I appreciate you guys
watching any last words for the weekend
they're not gonna see you for the entire
week it's Friday today yeah oh my god
did you really forget that is it's like
it might as well be Tuesday night oh
well its morning time okay just keep
what else do you have any messages
any special messages general I don't
know this is so much pressure okay guys
we'll see you on Monday
[Music]